okay so the topic of this video will be
viruses and the lytic cycle so let's go
ahead and get started so first of all
let's begin with what is a virus you
know when you look at the definition of
a virus it's pretty vague biological
particle composed of nucleic acid and
protein one of the more commonly known
facts of a virus is that they're
parasites but they're little different
than parasites that we typically think
of such as a tapeworm
viruses are intracellular parasites
meaning that they actually reside inside
of the cell of eye of a host and that's
what this video is going to focus on in
just a little bit well when we look at
this diagram we see the six kingdoms of
life plants animals fungus Protista and
then there's two bacterial kingdoms so
if something is alive on earth it's
classified in one of these six kingdoms
here so where do viruses fit in you know
the answer is nowhere viruses are not
classified as a living organism well
let's focus on that a little more right
now what I want to look at is you know
some of the characteristics that viruses
lack that really prevent them from being
classified as a living organism yet they
actually do possess some characteristics
in common with life well let's go ahead
and look at the no category on this
table here viruses are not considered
alive for a few reasons number one
they're not made of cells or organelles
they cannot reproduce on their own
without a host so here's a cell going
through mitosis you know viruses don't
do this viruses do not metabolize energy
what that means is they're not they're
like this caterpillar here they're not
herbivores like these wolves hunting
they're not carnivores
like this algae here they're they're not
autotrophs they don't feed they don't
take in energy
and they don't really perform any
cellular processes on their own so the
molecule of ATP right here should remind
you of the process called cellular
respiration well viruses don't produce
ATP and they don't perform cellular
respiration viruses do not do
photosynthesis viruses do not do DNA
replication however replication will be
an important topic in a little bit
viruses themselves do not do
transcription viruses themselves do not
do translation they don't possess the
organelles they don't possess the
enzymes they don't possess the machinery
in order to do these processes they
don't actively transport molecules into
and out of themselves so what about the
other side viruses do actually possess a
few characteristics in common with life
for instance viruses are able to
replicate they're able to make more of
themselves we're going to talk about the
lytic cycle in just a moment viruses
have nucleic acid viruses are are will
contain either DNA or RNA as their
genetic material but they do possess
nucleic acid as does every other form of
life on earth viruses are able to adapt
to their surroundings the picture here
shows some vials of of AZT which is an
HIV medication and HIV is actually the
virus HIV is adapting to the AZT
medication and therefore it's it's not
working the medication is not as
effective as it once was because the HIV
virus has adapted viruses have
organization to them they have parts
that do functions and we'll get into
some of these in just a moment
so when we look at the basic structure
of a virus I want to mention that the
shape and the size of viruses differ
from one another now they all do possess
a few characteristics in common for
instance you look at the three drawings
here and in each you'll see that the
three viruses all have what's called a
capsid and outer coating an outer layer
made up of protein and like the notes
say the protein coat to there or the
capsid surrounds nucleic acid well that
tells me the second thing that all
viruses have which is nucleic acid now
the three pictures show the viruses with
DNA inside and some viruses possess RNA
so it really does depend upon the virus
the virus on the Left labeled
bacteriophage has what almost looks like
creepy crawly legs on it for walking and
crawling around these are called tail
fibers and that's not what their
function is these tail fibers are used
for anchoring and attaching onto their
host cell so do they actually look do
these bacteria phages actually look like
this the answer is yes they actually do
now not all viruses look like this
bacteriophage right here but some of
them you can see are kind of got a
unique looking so let's start the
transition into how viruses actually
replicate you know here's a picture of a
bacteriophage and just mention these a
moment ago bacteria phages are viruses
but what's unique about them is they
actually infect bacteria so it's kind of
interesting that bacteria can even be
infected with viruses now we often will
study bacteria phages because how they
replicate is fairly similar to how
animal viruses that may get us sick for
instance also replicate so we can learn
a lot and apply it to human use now when
it comes to viral replication there's
really two two cycles to replication
pathways one is called the lytic cycle
and one
is called the lysogenic cycle the rest
of this video is really going to focus
on the lytic cycle I have a different
video if you'd like to learn more about
the lysogenic cycle so let's go ahead
and dive into the lytic cycle well we
can break the lytic cycle into some
stages and the first one is called
attachment like the name implies the
virus will attach and land onto a host
the cell membrane of a host and the
picture shows here's our host cell and
here comes a virus that has just
attached notice how there are these
little little objects on the outside of
the cell called receptors and what the
receptor will do is actually kind of
catch the virus and so the virus has
these little bumps on it made of protein
and with if the virus matches the
receptor then attachment will be
successful it's kind of like the lock
and key analogy here the virus acts as a
key the receptor acts as a lock and if
the virus is able to match the receptor
the cell not knowing anything is wrong
will draw the virus into itself and
that'll take us to step two step two is
call an entry and like the name implies
the virus will enter the host cell the
DNA or the RNA the nucleic acid will
enter the host now there's a couple ways
that this might happen
in some situations the virus will
literally inject the DNA or RNA into a
host cell that's what bacteria phages do
another way that the nucleic acid of the
virus can enter the cell is the entire
virus will ultimately be swallowed by
the cell and that's what this animation
is going to follow notice how a little
pocket has begun to form the cell is
actively swallowing the virus and taking
it into itself as the process continues
notice how the virus is drawn deeper
into the cell
and ultimately there you go the cell has
swallowed in swallowed up the the virus
and taking it inside of itself now what
happens is enzymes from the virus will
actually dissolve the outer capsid the
outer protein coat thus leaving behind
the nucleic acid of the virus so this
will now bring us the stage three called
replication and so what happens is the
virus DNA that you see will perform the
process called DNA replication to make
more viral DNA and that happens by the
viral DNA entering the nucleus of the
host cell and now we're going to see the
process of DNA replication the process
where DNA is used to make copies of more
DNA the reason the virus needs to go
into the nucleus is because that's where
the enzyme DNA polymerase is found and
so this enzyme DNA polymerase will
direct DNA replication notice what's
happening more DNA of the virus is being
copied and created well what happens
next is the virus DNA and in just a
moment the RNA that will create will be
used to make proteins that belong to the
virus well how does this occur this
occurs by the process of transcription
and translation if you forgotten what
transcription is transcription is the
process of creating RNA inside the
nucleus there's an enzyme called RNA
polymerase that will direct the process
of transcription notice what just
happened see a single strand of RNA was
just created and sent to a ribosome now
that the RNA of the virus is at a
ribosome the process called translation
can begin translation is the process of
creating proteins the difference being
the cell will actually be creating
proteins that belong to the virus
this translation process is performed by
ribosomes that's the job of a ribosome
to build proteins the ribosome doesn't
really realize that it's building
proteins for a virus so the ribosome
will read the viral RNA and begin to
build proteins that belong to the virus
and that's what the capsid of a virus is
made from the capsid of a virus is made
from proteins so the cells ribosomes are
actually building parts of future
viruses and now we come to the fourth
stage called assembly what happens is
the new viruses that have been created
start to self assemble notice how the
DNA comes together with the capsid and
when this occurs now we have brand-new
viruses that were just assembled inside
the cytoplasm of the host and so now we
come to the final stage called release
and what happens is focus on the
ribosome that you see in the picture
remember the ribosome is building
proteins that belong to the virus
another protein that the ribosomes
create that belongs to the virus are
enzymes and I've kind of drawn the
enzyme to be in the shape of scissors to
illustrate what these enzymes will do to
the cell so here's the ribosome making
enzymes enzymes that are ultimately
going to cause the host cell to lyse or
to burst and this is where the named
lytic come or lytic comes from it comes
from the word lyse which means to burst
so these enzymes that were just created
are going to pop little holes in the
cell membrane and ultimately that's
going to cause the cell to burst and the
viruses to be released
now once the viruses are released the
cycles simply going to repeat itself the
viruses are going to spread let's go
follow one of those viruses
so the viruses have spread and now
notice what's happened one of the new
viruses that just created has found
another hosts to infect to repeat the
cycle
and so that's kind of the the trickery
of the lytic cycle right there is that
even though the virus doesn't possess
any of the machinery to replicate and
make more of itself it will actually
hijack and take over a Cell which which
does possess the machinery to replicate
the virus so there you go I hope this
video was helpful if you're in my
biology class pause the video try to
answer these questions on a separate
sheet of paper I'd be happy to check
your answers before class or after class
thanks for watching